So what why are we here today, what are we doing?
We're here today on the set of British Vogue...
...to celebrate 10 years of Victoria Beckham.
We've put together looks from the last ten years...
...from the Victoria Beckham brand.
I think it's evolved, it's modern, it's minimal.
Victoria do you want to tell us what we're doing today?
Today we're here at Vogue and we are shooting a cover story...
...celebrating the rich and inspiring history of...
...one of the most enduring style icons of all time,...
...me, Victoria Beckham.
Everything she does is very simple, very pure, very pared down.
She's always moving forward.
She's not one to look back and that's what we love about her at Vogue.
This is where two fashion forces join to make something...
...really quite incredible.
She's an icon of style, Vogue is an icon of publishing...
...this really is where two become one.